[Musik]
ich bin auf jeden fall erleichtert dass
wir jetzt eine koalition zusammen haben
und dass wir jetzt einfach eine
funktionsfähige regierung haben die
jetzt auch beschlüsse vielseitiger
umsetzen kann ich muss sagen ich war mit
der bisher kann es doch nicht
unzufrieden und muss heute sagen ob das
jetzt wirklich besser war gewollt so und
na ja auf jeden fall umwelt
veröffentlicht lassen sich da nicht zu
sehr reinreden die grünen also das hoffe
ich am meisten klimaschutz natürlich
corona kurzfristig also jetzt die
nächste zeit erst mal und ansonsten
soziale gerechtigkeit dass die schere
nicht allzu weit auseinander geht
guten abend willkommen zum zdf spezial
gut vier wochen haben die ampel parteien
verhandelt jetzt steht der
koalitionsvertrag und der kurs der
künftigen regierung nimmt damit gestalt
an der vertrag ein geben und nehmen der
drei denkbar unterschiedlichen partner
mit dem ziel verbindliches
festzuschreiben und dauer streit zu
vermeiden schauen wir uns das mal
genauer an
der rot gelb grüne koalitionsvertrag
hält für jede ampel partei mindestens
ein herzensthema bereit die spd bekommt
den mindestlohn von 12 euro die grünen
haben sich beim kohleausstieg
durchgesetzt dieser soll falls möglich
bis 2030 gelingen steuererhöhungen sind
nicht geplant die wollte die fdp
verhindern außerdem wollen die neu
koalitionäre das wahlalter auf 16 senken
und cannabis legalisieren ganz oben auf
der to-do-liste ein corona krisenstab um
die pandemie endlich in den griff zu
kriegen
rund zwei monate nach der wahl also hat
sich inhaltlich einiges zurecht
geschüttelt und der weg ist frei für die
erste ampel koalition auf bundesebene
und die muss ich erst mal mit der
vierten corona welle befassen andrea
maurer
auftakt fürs ampel regieren den takt
dieses anfangs aber bestimmt die
pandemie und so beginnt auch der
wahrscheinliche künftige kanzler mit
einem maßnahmenpaket stadt mit dem
regierungsprogramm er will unter anderem
ein ständigen krisenstab im kanzleramt
eine milliarde für ein pflegekräfte
bonus auch zu impfpflicht äußert er sich
impfen ist der ausweg aus dieser
pandemie in einrichtung in den besonders
wohlhabende gruppen betreut werden
sollten wir die impfung verpflichtend
machen eine ausweitung dieser regelung
bleibt zu prüfen es ist die übernahme
von verantwortung nach wochen in denen
das land zwischen geschäftsführende
regierung und einer ampel in
koalitionsverhandlungen durch die vierte
welle gestolpert ist
was heute die ampel ist beginnt ende
september mit diesem self zu einer zeit
als die pandemie aus dem fokus gerückt
scheint
die euphorie der verhandler wird schnell
von der wirklichkeit einer sich immer
höher auftürmenden vierten welle
eingeholt als neue entscheider mit
parlamentarischer mehrheit für die ampel
noch vor einem monat die instrumente im
kampf gegen die pandemie reduzieren
nach unserer verständigung auch sind die
sehr einschneidenden maßnahmen nicht
mehr notwendig eine überschaubare
katalog niedrigschwelliger und auch
wenig eingriffs intensiver maßnahme eben
nicht mehr so tiefe eingriffsrechte
die maßnahmen müssen immer wieder
nachgeschärft werden am auslaufen der
epidemischen notlage morgen aber hält
die ampel fest
heute nun wieder 111 ii die selbst
auferlegte verschwiegen hat der
koalitionäre ist gebrochen was für die
verhandlung womöglich vorteil war
reduzierte kommunikation war in den
letzten wochen der korona krise eher
defizit auch die parteichefs von grünen
und fdp der eine soll vizekanzler und
chef eines superministerium wirtschaft
und klima der andere finanzminister
werden formulieren heute vor allem
verantwortungsbewusstsein
wir übernehmen oder werden die regierung
in einer zeit der krise übernehmen und
wir sind uns klar darüber dass wir alles
notwendige tun werden um die vierte
welle zu brechen das staatliche
krisenmanagement der künftigen
bundesregierung
wird sich verändern es wird optimiert
aber es wird nicht weniger konsequent
sein um schaden von diesem land
abzuwenden die bewältigung der pandemie
sei vordringlichste aufgabe heißt es im
koalitionsvertrag
das gesundheitsministerium geht an die
spd wer diese zentrale rolle übernehmen
soll das allerdings will die partei erst
nach dem parteitag am 14 12 verkünden
ich werde entsprechende vorschläge
machen das werden wir tun
nachdem die beratung über die bildung
des koalitionsvertrages und die
unterstützung des koalitionsvertrages in
der spd abgeschlossen sind und wir
nutzen die zeit
zeit aber ist das was in der vierten
welle kaum bleibt voraussichtlich am 8
12 ist kanzler war noch vor weihnachten
sollen die neuen ministerinnen und
minister ihre arbeit aufnehmen eine
handlungsfähige regierung wird dringend
gebraucht
und in berlin begrüße ich jetzt die spd
co vorsitzende saskia esken guten abend
guten abend der koalitionsvertrag ist in
trockenen tüchern ungleiche partner
haben sich da zusammen gerauft aber wie
krisenfest ist das corona wird die erste
nagelprobe
wir haben in den vergangenen wochen in
unseren verhandlungen und in unserem
stillhalten nach außen vor allem auch
doch sehr deutlich gezeigt dass da sehr
vertrauensvoll und vertraulich zusammen
gearbeitet wurde und wir gehen davon aus
so hat sich das die letzten wochen
angefühlt dass wir diese vertraulichkeit
und diese stärke die durch den durch den
weg den wir auch aufeinander zugehen
mussten auch hält nicht nur für diese
legislatur dass wir also eine gute basis
geschaffen haben für eine gute
zusammenarbeit die spd ist ja stärkste
partei sie wird mit olaf scholz den
kanzler stellen was wird da anders als
in der ära merkel wo ihre partei ja auch
mehrfach mitregiert hat das wird eine
sozialdemokratisch geführte regierung
sein und das wird auch klar und deutlich
werden dass ist auch spricht auch aus
dem koalitionsvertrag aber vor allem
wird sich verändern das ja insgesamt
alle partner die jetzt dort zusammen
arbeiten schon lange nicht oder schon
noch länger nicht mehr
zusammengearbeitet haben viele akteure
sind da nicht dabei gewesen jedenfalls
und insofern eine ganz neue ein ganz
neues bündnis es auch neue
vorgehensweisen und vor allem auch neue
konzepte finden wird für die
herausforderungen dieser zeit das zeigt
sich gerade auch bei corona jetzt mit
diesem mit diesem krisenstab mit diesen
pandemie rat mit einbeziehen der
expertise auch der der vielen der
virologen der dem ethik fachleute und
alle alle anderen experten die wir
brauchen um die situation auch gut zu
bewerten und eben auch der regelmäßigen
beratung die die keinen keinen wie die
mpk es immer zustande kamen auf zuruf
und auf die erste situation die
schwierig ist jetzt wollen wir uns
ständig beraten das ist auch richtig und
wichtig viele vorhaben kosten viel geld
die schuldenbremse aber soll weiter
gelten das klingt ein bisschen wie die
quadratur des kreises wie soll das
funktionieren
wir gehen davon aus dass der haushalt
auch durch die vorarbeit unseres noch
bundesfinanzministers geschäftsführern
bundesfinanzministers oder olaf schulz
gut vorbereitet ist auf diese phase wir
hatten ja in der auch in den vergangenen
jahren die mittel um notwendige
investitionen zu tätigen wir werden aber
auch privates geld hebeln und so eben
möglich machen das die investitionen
getätigt werden können die auch wichtig
sind vielen dank für das gespräch frau
nach berlin sehr gern
eines der ganz großen themen nicht nur
für die nächsten vier jahre ist die
klimakrise sie zu bekämpfen deutschland
klimaneutral zu machen das ist das
erklärte ziel der entstehenden neuen
regierung was genau unternommen werden
soll zeigt cornelia donath
auch ohne tempolimit dass es nicht in
den vertrag geschafft hat beim
klimaschutz drückt die ampel auf gas um
deutschland bis 2045 klimaneutral zu
machen soll der kohleausstieg jetzt wenn
möglich um acht jahre vorgezogen werden
bis 2030 dann sollen auch 80 prozent des
stroms aus erneuerbaren energien stammen
und jedes dritte auto voll elektrisch
unterwegs sein den verbrennungsmotor
will die ampel zwar hinter sich lassen
aber ohne konkretes datum freddys of
future reicht das alles nicht
das grundproblem mit dem
koalitionsvertrag ist ja bereits
klimaneutralität 20.45 denn das ziel
klimaneutral 20.45 zu sein reicht eben
nicht aus um einen gerechten beitrag zur
eindämmung der klimakrise zu heißen
deutschland müsste allerspätestens 20 35
bereits klimaneutral sein dafür müssten
die maßnahmen weit ambitionierter sein
als das was jetzt vorliegt
und im studio begrüße ich den zdf umwelt
experten volker angres guten abend
zeichnet sich mit diesem
koalitionsvertrag eine wende in der
klima- und umweltpolitik also mit
vorsichtigen optimismus kann man glaube
ich davon ausgehen es steht ja
geschrieben dass das vordringlichste
ziel leben ist der ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien mit einem
schwerpunkt wasserstoffwirtschaft grüner
wasserstoff der also auch co2 neutral
ist von einer europäischen wasserstoff
union ist da die rede man will
leitmärkte auch für wasserstoff schaffen
auch für elektromobilität das klingt
ganz gut unterm strich natürlich zählt
immer dann die umsetzung ja stichwort
erneuerbare energien du hast gerade
gesagt die sollen auf 80 prozent im
gesamtmix schach ansteigen das ist ein
hehres ziel aber ist das auch
realistisch wir liegen noch nicht mal
bei 50% im stromsektor wohlgemerkt die
anderen energieformen also wärme zum
beispiel sind da noch gar nicht
berücksichtigt dass wird knochenharte
arbeit denn wir sehen ja im moment dass
zb die genehmigung für einen neuen
windpark an die sechs jahre dauert das
kann natürlich nicht gelegen so viel
zeit haben wir unter gar keinen
umständen
da muss man sehen wie geht man mit
bürgerinitiativen um die gegen windparks
sind wie geht man mit den naturschützern
um die sich um greife sorgen machen die
geschreddert werden können das sind
alles riesen themen wie auch schon
bisher den ausbau verhindert haben da
muss man sehr gespannt sein wie das
gelingen kann da ist noch viel arbeit
liegt davor der neue kollege was
deutschland für sich beschließt das
macht ja im globalen maßstab nicht so
einen großen unterschied kann die
klimawende ich hier so eine art
dominoeffekt auslösen und auch andere
staaten zum umlenken bewegen ja in der
tat wenn deutschland klimaneutrales
heißt das noch lange nicht dass wir das
paris ziel von 15 grad erderwärmung
dieses limit tatsächlich erreichen
werden im koalitionsvertrag für mich neu
ist auch die forderung einer neuen klima
außenpolitik gegeben das heißt es geht
in richtung internationale kooperation
und da hat glasgow leon die
un-klimakonferenz gerade den weg geebnet
das ist jetzt möglich auch beim thema
wasserstoff mit sonnenreichen ländern
zusammenzuarbeiten kooperationen zu
schmieden um zb in südafrika in indien
auch schneller dort aus der kohle
auszusteigen mit know how was wir hier
entwickeln das war bis jetzt nicht so
vernetzt gedacht also klima aus und
politik klima entwicklungspolitik und
das technische know how was wir hier
haben und was ich auch ganz
bemerkenswert findet der begriff
technologie offenheit kommt sehr oft vor
im koalitionsvertrag und da kann man nur
sagen da hat sich die fdp durchgesetzt
zum beispiel auch beim thema
synthetische kraftstoffe die sind nicht
mehr raus die sind wieder drin wenn den
verbrenner motoren nachweislich damit
wird betankt werden jedenfalls sehen wir
da eine dynamik zwischen glasgow und
medien vielen dank für das gespräch frau
angriff
die ampel also regiert demnächst
deutschland die viertgrößte
volkswirtschaft der welt was ändert sich
was bleibt für industrie und handel mehr
fortschritt wagen das land
digitalisieren
wohlstand und klimaschutz vereinen
und wie genau soll das gehen das sagt
der koalitionsvertrag zu den
wirtschaftspolitischen zielen
die ampel verspricht für die wirtschaft
ein jahrzehnt der zukunftsinvestitionen
insbesondere bei klimaschutz
digitalisierung bildung und forschung
sowie infrastruktur bis 2030 soll
deutschland zum leitmarkt für
wasserstoff technologie und
elektromobilität werden bei der
digitalisierung will die ampel planungs
und genehmigungsverfahren deutlich
beschleunigen trotzdem sollen ab 2023
die vorgaben der schuldenbremse wieder
eingehalten werden
vieles geht in die richtige richtung
der fokus liegt darauf
wachst du mit klimaschutz und
digitalisierung zu verbinden und das ist
von der richtung her in ordnung die
große frage ist jetzt wie wird das alles
konkretisiert und wie wird das
finanziert auch dazu steht einiges drin
aber da wird man noch viele ausarbeiten
müssen vom wirtschafts experten des ifo
instituts zum vize-präsidenten des
cdu-wirtschaftsrats friedrich merz der
bekanntermaßen auch ein kandidat für den
parteivorsitz ist gut nach arnsberg
guten abend der fornoff die ampel steht
ihr geplanter kurs ist in konturen
zumindest sichtbar geworden mehr
fortschritt wagen deutschland
digitalisieren um nur mal zwei
überschriften zu nennen da kann man ja
als opposition kaum dagegen sein oder
zunächst einmal hervor auf eine kleine
korrektur ich bin seit heute nicht mehr
vize präsident des wirtschaftsrates sich
auf das heute noch gemäß abgegeben mit
der heutigen mitgliederversammlung weil
ich wirklich richtig stellt vorbereitet
aber dies nur am konnten sie nicht
wissen wohl nur am rand ja das ist ein
interessanter koalitionsvertrag etwas
schwierig zu lesen also literatur
nobelpreis wird es dafür nicht geben
aber viel handschrift fdp das sieht man
an vielen stellen auch in der
wirtschaftspolitik auch in der
umweltpolitik einiges an vernunft sie
haben zwei drei themen gerade
angesprochen das ganze wird allerdings
in seiner wirklich großen ambitionierten
weise nur gehen wenn das auch einhergeht
mit einer durchgreifenden
entbürokratisierung in deutschland die
verfahren müssen kürzer werden schneller
werden das sollen sie auch dann wird
aber auch das beteiligungsrecht der
verbände etwa eingeschränkt werden
müssen also man darf gespannt sein ob
die koalition diese sehr ambitionierten
ziele tatsächlich auch erreicht die neue
regierung wird sie also die union
spätestens im bundesrat immer wieder
brauchen bei den corona maßnahmen haben
sie bereits mit blockade gedroht ist das
jetzt für sie das machtinstrument der
wahl
nein wir drohen nicht mit blockade und
wir haben auch nicht blockiert er vom
hof in der letzten woche haben die
ministerpräsidenten auch der
unionsgeführten bundesländer
der änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes jahr zugestimmt
der bundesrat ist kein
blockadeinstrument das ist das
instrument in dem die länder interessen
wahrgenommen werden und so muss es auch
bleiben wir werden im bundestag unsere
eigenen vorstellungen einbringen die
länder werden dem bundesrat ihre
vorstellungen einbringen wichtig ist
dass wir gemeinsam dieses land
voranbringen und jetzt so modernisieren
dass wir diesen ansprüchen gerecht
werden können auf der einen seite
klimaneutral zu werden auf der anderen
seite aber auch industrieland zu bleiben
und das wird die spannende frage auch
wirtschaftspolitisch die mit diesem
koalitionsvertrag und dann auch mit der
anschließenden koalition beantwortet
werden muss eine kurze frage zu corona
noch mit der bitte um eine ebenfalls
kurze antwort ist das was da beschlossen
wurde im infektionsschutzgesetz
ausreichend oder fehlt ihnen was
wir hätten einen anderen weg bevorzugt
nämlich den zu lassen den wir
eingefahren und erprobt hatten die
koalition hat sich noch vor der
regierungsbildung entschlossenes
grundlegend zu ändern das wird man sehen
und ich habe sehr wohl vernommen wie
herr scholz heute vorsichtig geantwortet
hat auf die frage nach einer impfpflicht
ob das ausreicht dahinter machen wir ein
großes fragezeichen ist wäre gut wenn
wir alle möglichst schnell aus dieser
krise herauskommen und das geht nur mit
konsequentem staatlichem handeln vielen
dank für das gespräch friedrich merz
sehr gern und
wir schauen noch mal rein in den
koalitionsvertrag wohin soll die reise
in der sozialpolitik gehen auch dass ein
querschnittsthema mit dem sich
verschiedene ministerien beschäftigen
werden beim sozialen hat die ampel pläne
für jung und alt vorgesehen für die
kleinen ist eine kindergrundsicherung
geplant die alle bisherigen leistungen
bündelt außerdem sollen kinderrechte im
grundgesetz verankert werden
junge menschen sollen eine garantie auf
einen ausbildungsplatz bekommen für
pflegekräfte ist mehr geld ein bonus und
ein besserer personalschlüssel
vorgesehen und für die senioren neuem
vertrag eine aktien rente für alle über
einen fonds der unabhängig und seriös
verwaltet werden soll die ampel will ein
bürgergeld statt hartz 4 1 führen
wohlfahrtsverbänden geht das nicht weit
genug
ein bürgergeld hat hier muss man sagen
dass das was wir jetzt in dem vertrag
finden noch nicht die versprochenen
überwindung von hartz 4 ist das sind
vielleicht 50 prozent das war nämlich
jetzt als aktions moratorium einführt es
wird ein jahr lang eine sanktion
ausgesprochen
man will dann sehen wie man den ganzen
bereich wesentlich humaner gestaltet als
jetzt aber was zu einer bindung von
hartz4 gehörte wäre eine deutliche
erhöhung der regelsätze da zeigt der
vertrag ein blinder fleck außerdem im
koalitionsvertrag ein einmaliger
heizkostenzuschuss für
einkommensschwache familien und um
wohnen wieder bezahlbar zu machen sollen
400.000 neue wohnungen jährlich gebaut
werden davon 100.000 öffentlich
gefördert
und im studio begrüße ich den
politikwissenschaftler karl rudolf korte
guten abend gute nacht noch eine
nachfrage zum thema sozialpolitik werden
die kleinen film gerade gesehen von den
großen reformen ist da im
koalitionspapier ja erst mal nicht die
rede aber die sicherungssysteme zum
beispiel die rente müsste man doch
eigentlich jetzt dringend fit machen für
die zukunft eigentlich schon denn auch
sozialpolitik insgesamt sichert die
qualität der demokratie aber der
koalitionsvertrag kommt in vielen teilen
zumutung frei daher auch bei diesem
thema die ampel ist ja relativ
geräuschlos bis jetzt eher ins ziel
gekommen inhaltlich gibt es aber
bekanntermaßen ja jede menge differenzen
auch programmlich wie stabil kamen so an
bündnis seien sehr weil das
politikverständnis auf verschiedenheit
ausgerichtet ist wie eine versöhnte
verschiedenheit kommt dass heute her und
der beleg ist dieses aggressive
schweigen während der letzten wochen das
schafft man nur wenn vertrauen wächst
und wechselseitig man sich über ziele
verständigen kann wie viel kontinuität
oder wie viel wandel oder beides
erwarten sie im vergleich zur ära merkel
ja formal kontinuität aber in der sache
groß unterschiedlichkeit der politik
begriff ist nicht problemlösung sondern
die lernende koalition die wir heute
erlebt haben möchte gestalten und das
ist etwas anderes ist es nicht nur
krisen management sondern modernisierung
in die neue regierung sie ganz gerade
auch gesagt die nimmt sich ja eine ganze
menge vor vom klimaschutz bis zur
digitalisierung was sind denn für sie
messbare erfolgskriterien
letztlich ob man wieder gewählt wird das
ist natürlich bei drei partnern einfach
an der mehrheit hinzubekommen als bei
zwei partner aber zentral wird
erfolgreich im moment die frage sein wie
man corinna politik bekämpft das ist
pflicht der winter kommt auch ja das ist
pflicht und eigentlich ist das programm
dahinter kühe ja vielen dank für dieses
gespräch gern
keine indiskretion keine
durchstechereien mindestens im stil
haben die drei parteien an guten ton
gesetzt am koalitionsvertrag werden sich
jetzt viele abarbeiten die erste
härteprüfung für die ampel koalition
aber läuft schon und sie heißt corona ob
es gelingt die vierte welle zu brechen
wird wesentlich darüber entscheiden ob
der ampel staat als erfolgreich
anzusehen ist das war unser zdf spezial
mehr informationen jederzeit auf zdf
heute.de und später im heute-journal und
dort sehen sie auch ein gespräch mit dem
designierten neuen bundeskanzler olaf
scholz einen schönen abend ihnen und auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]